so you're in Westminster Hall when the
president of Ukraine addressed MPS it
must have been quite a moment it was as
soon as I heard president zielinski was
going to be coming to Westminster Hall I
kind of canceled everything in my diary
and and went straight there Westminster
Hall is an incredibly historic place
it's there's been a hall there for 900
years and over the centuries some
extraordinary historic things have have
happened there from the the trial of
King Charles the first all kinds of
things have happened in that place uh
more recently great Statesmen have
addressed both houses of Parliament
people like Nelson Mandela and Barack
Obama and I think when people look back
at president zielinski's address today
to both houses of Parliament and many
other hundreds of people as well they
will look back on that as something that
is similarly historic uh the the a war
leader the leader of a a nation whose
very survival is being threatened by an
aggressor you know coming to speak to
one of the oldest democracies in the
world we're doing everything we can to
support them it was quite a I think it
was quite a special moment that he came
and spoke to us in that way I think I'm
certainly going to remember it for the
rest of my life and I suspect other
people who are there will as well I
guess we don't know how the story of the
Ukraine war ends I mean it was very
clear wasn't it it was only President
zelinski's second visit out of Ukraine
since the beginning of the war he knew
why he was here he was here because he
was asking for jets is he going to get
them well president zlinski has
obviously asked the West for military
Support over the last year and the
United Kingdom has been leading Europe
in providing that support I mean most of
the Challenger tanks the missiles
um the air defense systems 2.3 billion
pounds worth last year in the same this
year and now the Jets and I think the
Prime Minister has said today that he
has tasked the our defense secretary Ben
Wallace with looking into how we can
help with that request nothing is off
the table I take it from that that there
is no objection in principle because
otherwise he wouldn't have asked the
defense secretary to go and look into
this they're obviously
some questions around training because
the training to fly one of these Jets
can take a while
um yes right yeah well it came in
ordinary times take years that's that's
right um but the fact that the primary
app prime minister Rishi sunak has asked
to defend the UK defense secretary
um to look into this I think is a pretty
clear signal of intent I don't get it
right because I take you how you read
this right but I genuinely am a bit
confused I can't work out if he says
he's going to look at this he's asked
Ben Wallace to have a look at it I can't
work out if that is kicking it into the
long grass or if that means we are
actually going to send Jets can you
clarify well I think it's it
demonstrates serious intent right yeah
what does that means I'm not sure what
that means I think I'm clearly sending
um jets and working out the training
that would go around those is not a like
a straightforward
um exercise right these are very
complicated bits of equipment
um as you said ordinarily it takes five
years to train to fly one of these
pieces of kid so it's not
straightforward and I think what the
Prime Minister means he wants the
defense secretary
um to look at the practicalities of how
that could be made to work but the fact
he's asked him to do that suggests to me
um that there's no in principle
objection to doing it it suggests to me
that there is um serious intent but it's
got to be but it's but it's got to be
worked through in a in a proper
thoughtful way is there a genuine
concern about what this means when it
comes to the war and how Russia will see
this because you know the Russian
Ambassador at a billion said about tanks
that it was an extremely dangerous
decision it takes a conflict to a new
level of Confrontation the Kremlin have
come out to you know condemn the idea of
jets as well according to a Russian news
agencies are we concerned about what it
means we don't mean an escalation the
Russians have made these kind of
comments previously we are helping a a
sovereign free Democratic country defend
themselves from an unconscionable Act of
aggression which is which is included
um deliberately targeting and murdering
civilians we are perfectly within our
rights to do anything that we feel
necessary to help the ukrainians defend
themselves I personally see no in
principle reason why that shouldn't
include Jets to prevent women and
children getting getting killed which is
happening as we speak and I don't think
we should allow comments by a regime
like Putin's to deter us from doing that
we're supporting and helping a free
Democratic Nation defend themselves and
defend civilians from a barbaric attack
so does it raise our Threat Level
um well we we've seen we've seen we've
seen the Russians employ rhetoric in the
past we're obviously always very
thoughtful about our own security
um but I think you know there is no need
for us to be
apologetic or or defensive about helping
a free Democratic Nation defend itself
so it's it's worth it it's the argument
that you would give that even if it does
increase the Threat Level from Russia
it's worth it because of the democratic
principle well I'm not sure I'm
accepting the kind of premise of the
questions I think it may be rhetorical
what I am what I am what I am saying is
that this is a free Democratic country a
European country being brutally attacked
civilians are being deliberately
targeted murdered by the Russian regime
and I think in those circumstances we
should do everything we can to help them
defend themselves and I think president
zielinski made an interesting point in
his speech today he talked about
um how he'd been to the cabinet War
rooms in the past sat in Churchill's uh
chair and he talked about how making
sure Russia does not succeed in their uh
murderous and illegal objectives will
that will act as actually a deterrent to
other aggressive countries that may
think about doing this kind of thing
indeed to Russia itself and actually by
helping Ukraine in their fight for their
own Survival we're actually making the
whole world a safer place because it
means aggressive regimes like Putin just
think twice or think three times or
perhaps don't do it at all when they
look over their borders at neighboring
countries so I think being being firm
and supporting Ukraine actually over
viewed in the round makes the world
safer
um one other question on Ukraine and we
focus a lot on Jets I have to say I've
been my ears picked up when Russia sunak
was talking about long-range missiles
saying that actually this is what he
spent most at the time talking about
long-range missiles Boris Johnson also
called for them to be provided should
they be it wasn't the Prime Minister
himself which is soon like was was clear
about the importance of doing that I
mean he's been actively discussing that
with president zelinski is that going to
happen today what's going to happen it's
for the Prime Minister and defense
secretary to make those kind of
announcements it's not for me but it's
been quite clear from his comments the
Prime Minister was actively discussing
that today and again it helps the
ukrainians defend themselves against
this barbaric attack eventually attack
Russia as well well we're helping
Ukraine defend themselves from this
barbaric attack and I think any
Sovereign Nation has the right to do
that and I think we have a right if
anything we have a moral G it's more
than the right we have a duty um to help
them defend themselves not just because
it's the right thing to do because it
makes the world a safer place and now on
a um I think many people like would
completely agree with the comments that
you make about the importance of
supporting Ukraine and one other issue
that I'm quite Keen to talk to you about
is that we've seen the re-emergence so
we say if you're from a boss uh Liz
trust you obviously served in her
treasury when she was prime minister it
made a appearance at pmqs too I just
want to listen to the SNP leader uh
Stephen uh Flynn and you know what's
coming
no the former prime minister won't
apologize for the damage that she has
caused so on behalf of the Tory party
well he apologized for her
I mean there is an argument that really
seen like shouldn't be apologizing
because he didn't serve uh he ran
against Liz truss he described her ideas
as fantasy economics you obviously did
serve in her cabinet would you like to
apologize well English trust actually
did Apologize at the time for the
turmoil um that occurred but since um
Richardson came uh to become Prime
Minister three or so months ago and the
various um market indices have basically
returned to where they were before so
the currency I remember maybe even come
on your show and you have some charts on
the wall yeah I remember this one yeah
that's right and the currency had gone
from he was 113 against the dollar it
went down it's now actually up above
where it was last time I checked a week
or two ago um above where it was um when
she came to office and the similar is
true of bond yields so that's reverted
to normal we've got
um uh GDP growth last year uh 2022 in
the UK that was higher than any other G7
country
um so I think you know we can now look
to the Future we've got a very low
unemployment um in my lifetime I'm 46 is
the lowest appointment almost in my
lifetime obviously challenges the cost
of living that we need to we need to
face up to
um but but I think we're in a in a good
position good place I wouldn't be doing
my job if I didn't point out other
economic indicators for showing that for
example we're still got the only G7
economy with a smaller economy than a
pre-pandemic to talk about mortgage
rates for example which certainly
haven't returned to normal but I guess
what I'm interested in right is you know
you said there about how we've done
different interviews at different times
over the last few months which we
certainly have you know you came in here
to defend this truss you're now here
defending wish you soon talking up his
Economic Policy as you did just then I
mean that's pretty tough going isn't it
do you have Whiplash well I think I mean
ideas for distress and I did support the
idea of having lower taxes clearly um
but you know you've got to have a couple
of reasons why that didn't wasn't
accepted by the financial markets and
clearly the financial markets did reject
the approach but that was for a number
of reasons one was there weren't um
spending reductions to fund the tax cuts
and there wasn't obr scoring so there
was a violent Market reaction that we
talked about at the time and that's why
a different approach was then uh was
then needed you have to deal with
reality uh as you encounter it and
clearly the markets reacted um very
badly and so
um that's why there was a change and
that's why Rishi came in and and did
what he did what he did which is broadly
speaking work those numbers have now
reverted to where they were before
mortgage rates have gone up across the
world here in the UK they've basically
gone back pretty much to where they were
you know in in August or or September
before the mini budget but there is
still a lot more work to do Across the
Western World on the cost of living
inflation and so on and so forth it's
interesting you're talking about the
market reaction and mentioning the obr
because obviously Liz trusted and her
article in the Sunday Telegraph as well
she blamed a powerful economic
establishment for some of the issues she
faced she also said the offers for
Budget responsibility you know the
effectively the Watchdog they kind of
Mark the government's homework if you
like she accused them of putting fiscal
policy in straight jacket and said she
disagreed with their assessment do you
think she's right on the those things um
look I'm not gonna I'm not going to
offer a kind of running commentary on on
what Liz has been has been saying I
think what is clear is that the approach
taken
um wasn't accepted by the markets part
of that I think was the fact that there
wasn't
um an obr scoring now you can debate the
Rights and Wrongs of the obr but the the
sort of fact was the financial markets
didn't didn't like the way it was
presented we wouldn't put them as part
of the kind of economic establishment
then you'd say that that's just that's a
reflection of the policy I think
ultimate ultimately that the problem was
with the financial markets right the
financial markets didn't like
um the way the package was put together
um you can debate the reasons for that
but they certainly didn't like it and
that's why
um a correction ended up getting getting
made in the correction has essentially
worked
um just finally um because she did
mention how you liked the ideas of lower
taxes what is your position on Lower
taxes now would you like to see taxes
come down
but I think it's got to be done in a way
that yes I would um it needs to be done
though in a way that is responsible
because we saw
what happens if the market reacts badly
so I think you know for that to happen
uh we need a certain amount of economic
growth I think the the path we're set on
uh will ultimately deliver that um but
but time will time will tell we
certainly had a I mean 20 we got all
these sort of headlines talking about uh
the UK not doing well but I mean 2021 we
had record goes from the G7 2022 last
calendar year we had record growth in
the G7
um again so and we've got very very low
unemployment indeed we're about to see
the minimum wage go up in a few weeks
Time by I think around about 10 which
will help people obviously on Lower
incomes so I hope we do get
circumstances where we can reduce taxes
but it's got to be done in a way
obviously that is um that is responsible
and doesn't cause
um a negative Market reaction okay thank
you very much because I've got the scars
the last one